so this is the one i always save it for
mostly last even though it probably
should be first but it's the idea of
writing with a clear objective
you want people to do something and
there's no shame in that and i find
especially
women that i know do have shame about
that so stop that
it's no there's no shame in making a
sale or or using marketing for lead gen
which is what you should be doing right
there's a reason why you're writing this
social post and it's not to share with
people what breakfast cereal you're
enjoying or not enjoying it's it's too
it's for legion i mean really should be
so you want to identify what the
objective is and work backwards
i like to think of of the the macro the
micro goals first right so in social
there's only two objectives their
conversion which means like a click
or reach which is a share right so it's
very easy click or share
that's all i want you to do as a smaller
company it's much harder to get people
to actually click any content because
they don't trust you yet
but it's very easy to get them to share
when people are sharing they're doing it
because it's about their ego
they're taking credit for what you said
really right so it's kind of like when
someone recommended you a great album
in college and then you share it with
your friends you get the credit
not not the friend who started the thing
right so think about that if you is what
you're writing
touching on the ego enough to give
someone a reason to
reshare this and look good because
you're giving giving them
you know that little golden nugget and
then clicks by the way like i said it's
harder when you're
a younger business but in the case
except for in the case of how to
so how to's click galore so anytime you
can
write a blog that's like how to do your
hair
or how to write copy smarter and more
effectively whatever it is
videos podcasts whatever how-tos are
super when there